question est un vote de
confiance. Il n'a pas répondu
députés pensent que oui. Les
consommateurs sont à la ch
juste avant le vote. Ils ont
demandé au leader de la maman
de confiance? Le leader indique
on passe. On n'a pas le temp
discuter de ça.
- Il y a longtemps qu'on avaitve
marcher paisiblement
devant le Parlement.nsnsnsnsnsnr
été chassés du centre-ville
d'OttaJuJuJustin Trudeau
croit que la Loi sur
les mesures d'urgence
INININININININININININININININI,
premier ministre du Canada- - -t
présent, la situation est encore
fragile. La situation d'urgence
- Présente, selon lui,
parce qu'il y a des menaces
de récidives. Des manifestants
se trouvent encore dans
la région d'Ottawa. Les postes
de nouveau être ciblés.
- Nous allons continuer
de surveiller au jour le jour
pour voir quand est-ce
qu'on pourra le lever.
- M. Boulerice.
- À la tête d'un nenenenement
minoritaire, les libéraux ont
pu bénéficier de l'appui du NPD,
même si le chef ononononononono.
JAGMEET SINGH, chef du NPD
- Notre décisiitititit basée
vraiment sur la menace. On pense
que oui, oui, il y a une menace
et on dovavavavavavavavavavavavà
indiqué qu'ils allaient voter
contre la loi, qu'ils n'estiment
LUC BERTHOLD, chef adjoint
du Parti conservat
- Est-ce qu'on devait avoir
besoin de cette loi-là
pour que lesononononononononono?
On ne le croit pas.
- Zéroetetetetet
zéro manifestants.
- Un point de vue partagé
l l l l l l l l l l l l l l l n
préventive est abusif.
TITITITITINA MICHAUD,
députée du Bloc Québécois
- Alors, combien de temps
veut laisser en vigueur
les mesures d'urgence?
en vigueur pour l'éternité?
Je me demande si elle est
- Un rejet de la chambre hau